elle avait juré qu'il n'y remettrai
jamais les pieds à auschwitz
lusine de la mort myriam ziegler peut
compter sur sa fille pour enfin
affronter son douloureux passé par
schiste jennequin émérite si myriam est
une survivante d'auschwitz où elle a
vécu pendant un an
libérée lorsque les soviétiques ont
découvert le camp de concentration le 27
janvier 1945 elle faisait partie des
deux cents enfants garder en vie pour
servir de cobaye dans des expériences
nazis la voici exhibant son tatouage de
prisonnier lors de sa libération
il n'avait que neuf ans j'étais heureuse
d'être enfin libre se souvient myriam il
n'y avait plus d'allemands pour nous
tuer plus d'horribles expériences
scientifiques
la photo d'elle et de ses amis a fait le
tour du monde
mais ce n'est qu'après avoir refait sa
vie au canada et avoir eu trois enfants
que myriam a vu la photo pour la
première fois dans un musée en israël en
1981 elle a accepté de replonger au
coeur des horreurs pour la première fois
en 70 ans myriam reconnaître aux biens
les édifices les chambres à gaz
les fours crématoires elle se rappelle
aussi ses barbelés six fils barbelés qui
était partout puis l'endroit par où sont
arrivés les libérateurs russe caire
l'émotion est trop forte
peut-être que ce retour à auschwitz où
myriam rencontrera plus tard certains de
ses amis survivants pour recréer sa
célèbre photo chassera les démons qui
reviennent encore là en t il si philippe
leblanc radio canada toronto